bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
minute forme je suis votre coach Nicolas
je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui un
mouvement à l'aide d'un simpl man
chabalet le squat bras tendus
aujourd'hui avec Delia bonjouria bonjour
Comment vas-tu ça va la forme je vais te
montrer le mouvement du du squat bras
tendu d'accord je vais décomposer et
ensuite tu vas devoir l'effectuer avec
pas mal de répétitions ça marche al dans
un premier temps tu vas prendre ton
manche à baller sur une prise large tu
vas écarter tes pieds un peu plus large
que la largeur des hanches placer ton
manche au-dessus de la tête et tu vas
effuer une flexion de jambes tu vas
contracter tes abdos descendre la
position et remonter
d'accord bien lever la poitrine engager
tes épaules serrer tes abdos pousser les
genoux vers
l'extérieur et tu remonte à toi de jouer
tu vas ouvrir un petit peu plus tes
mains sur la barre tu vas la serrer
d'accord et tu vas placer
celle-ci de ta tête très bien tu vas
engager tes épaules ça va te demander un
gros travail vraiment au niveau deltoïde
pied un tout petit peu plus lar pour
pouir descendre tu vas rentrer serrer
ton ventree la sang abdominale va
travailler et tu vas descendre sur cette
position de squat en flexion de jambe tu
descends poussant les fesses légèrement
vers l'arrière les genoux vers l'avant
et tu remontes très bien déjà tu repars
sur le même mouvement descends tu dois
être en appui sur tes talons et tu
repousses dans les talons pour remonter
là tu as l'action des cuisses des
fessiers et tout le Tron ça marche allez
tu m'enchaînes quelques répétitions
c'est
parti essaie de gagner quelques
centimètres mettre vers le bas
amplifie le
mouvement P à souffler en montant
inspire et souffle essaie de bien
trouver ton équilibre en gardant la
barre vraiment sit tué auudessus de ta
tête allez encore une fois continue Go
descends très bien c'est bon tu peux
relâcher alors comment tu te sens ça va
où est-ce que tu as senti le travail
ici as senti autre part bon travail
super nous avons vu le squat bras tendu
je vais vous montrer maintenant
l'étirement correspondant à cet exercice
on a beaucoup sollicité les cuisses mais
l'effort le plus intense est effectué
sur le travail du dos je vais vous
montrer un étirement sur votre dos on y
va allez positionne tes pieds largeur de
tes hanches tu vas glisser tes cuisses
tes coudes sur tes cuisses pardon et tu
vas arrondir le dos et écarter les
omoplates d'accord et tu maintiens tu
vas ouvrir pour étirer ton bas du dos
essaie de faire comme un petit chat tu
ouvrees le tu ouvre le dos pour arrondir
tu dois sentir l'étirement sur toute la
longueur tu maintiens la position pousse
sur tes coudes respire et tout doucement
tu reviens d' plat et tu peux te
redresser très bien tu l'as senti cette
é tiement on se revoit bientôt à bientôt
j'espère que tu vas continuer à
travailler cet exercice j'espère qu'il
t'a plu à très bientôt au revoir à tous
merci de nous avoir suivi rendezv pour
de prochains épisodes dans minutes forme
overhead squat squat bras tendus les
zones sollicitées sont le dos les
cuisses les fessiers et les épauules
attention à la courbure naturelle du dos
qui n'est pas respecté au mauvais
alignement hanche épaule cheville et à
la sangle abdominale et les muscles du
dos qui ne sont pas suffisamment
engagés